[Music]
right here we have for a matinee show
now even though we're doing the review
from our little office and stuff here we
did actually go to the theater to see
this one yeah this is a new movie this
is a new movie this is the art of
self-defense yeah interesting movie
taking place looks like to be in the
late 80s early 90s maybe yeah I was
thinking 92 based on the computers and
stuff but they don't really say and it's
like it doesn't really matter I guess
but yeah in a way it's almost kind of
like a Karate Kid type movie but it's
really deadpan but really yeah it turns
out to be kind of like a Karate Kid
movie from the dark side don't want to
spoil it
it's I enjoyed the movie though yeah it
took me a while to kind of understand
where this movie was coming from where I
was gonna go I thought it was gonna be
kind of a pretty silly ass comedy and
it's not really it's almost kinda like I
started to go into the realm of almost
like horror it's a dark comedy for sure
it reminded me a lot and I think it's
kind of significant that it was
supposedly set in like the early 90s
because it reminded me of a lot of indie
movies from that time period
it actually you know what okay people
who like um Wes Anderson movies
if you liked like a lot of that really
like deadpan ironic distance type of
stuff like from the 90s because there
was a lot of indie movies like that in
the 90s you would love that kind of
stuff
Charlie Kaufman like if you liked like
Synecdoche New York and stuff like that
you would probably dig this it's a
similar kind of thing um I would call it
a dark comedy but like I said I don't
really want to give too much away
because yeah I only saw one trailer for
this so I wasn't really sure like I got
an idea of the vibe but I had no idea
like where the plot was gonna go and so
and I'm glad I didn't know because I was
just kind of like oh we're going we're
doing this now yeah
about this guy in his 30s he's like a
super beta office worker yeah played by
Jesse Eisenberg Ian
I think he's like maybe 130 132 I think
he's 35 is 35 yeah but it's like an
accountant that guy is just so weak that
he's almost like a little kid and he was
walking leaves out late last wait late
one night walking to get some dog food
and he gets attacked by a motorcycle
gang beat him up so he decides that he's
gonna get a gun
but then he kind of gets kind of
chickens out from getting the gun and
instead decides to take karate class and
he just gets into karate gets his ass
whipped and he makes it
you know his sensei tries to man him up
you know and it's a lot of weird [ __ ]
happens and one thing leads to another
backing up just thinking about it yeah
yeah it's it's a tale of honor you know
in a way in a very strange way yeah it's
like I said this is a very weird movie
like I said if you like a lot of those
90s if you like Wes Anderson if you like
anything like um your go slant the most
like the guy that did the lobster and
the favorite and stuff like that it's a
very similar kind of tone and it almost
goes like in a thriller almost like a
Fight Club direction like it and it like
you said it's almost like a horror movie
but not quite yeah I didn't really
expect it to go where it went and like
honestly I'm I'm thinking about like the
last part of it like the last scene I'm
not gonna spoil it or anything like that
and I'm just like I'm internally like
cracking up at how funny that [ __ ]
saying I was just busted a lot and it is
a karate movie it yeah it is very much
centered on it's almost yeah about dojo
life in the honor of the dojo and it is
a karate movie it's just unlike any
karate movie I've ever seen even though
the rules of honor are followed the
rules of karate are honor are kind of
followed in a way but there's more than
just that kind of honor you have to you
have to see the movie I don't want to
steal the movies Thunder the movie it's
just if you like Karate Kid
and you like horror movies then you
should probably see and you like really
drives us yeah and you like comedy the
sense of humor and this reminds me a
little bit of the other one we did the
other that Jim Jarmusch movie the dead
don't die it's just like there's very
long scenes of like just people's facial
expressions and let everyone is just
soso deadpan and it's kind of a similar
type of thing and this dude is so beta
that it's uncomfortable to watch him
it's interesting because he doesn't
usually play parts like yeah he's
usually like kind of like an over the
top like he usually plays nerdy
characters but he's usually I think he
played like Mark Zuckerberg in the
social network when that that movie they
did about Facebook you know so he
usually plays like these super hyper you
know geek type like genius geek types so
he was kind of playing a little bit
against type in this but I think he did
a really good job yeah and that it I
don't know it's just like that and did
you realize that the guy that's like the
sensei of the dojo that's his name is
sensei that's the only if you like
eighties movies and eighties karate
movies this might be for you I like
those yeah but this is just like a very
different take on that yeah even though
it still is it still is what it is yeah
and but not really it's just like I said
it's it isn't this is almost kind of
like an artsy movie definitely is it's F
it's not usually the kind of movie I
enjoy but the way it was done when I
came out of the theater I was like yeah
okay alright yeah some of the scenes in
this were so so funny and like
especially like the end it was just kind
of the end of it is almost kind of like
the punchline of like a really long
involved joke it's like when they say it
like that when the end of it happens I
just like I said I just busted out
laughing and it's hard to talk about it
without spoiling it yeah i can't spoil
it you know what i mean there's a lot of
there was a lot of nostalgia for me
there was some you
early 90s and late eighties motorcycles
in it before I went off into the army
you know some of the dorky friends that
I had that were that were in the in my
step-brother and [ __ ] they were into [ __ ]
of martial arts even though my
step-brother went a dork is a he was a
Taekwondo you know black belt he was a
badass I mean that he really could whip
your ass but he could whip your ass
without Taekwondo that's what kind of
guy he was
yeah but then I had another buddy I was
coming up with who is just the total
total dork and kind of a wannabe that
was into all that karate and ninja
throwing stars and [ __ ] one-inch
punches and [ __ ] like that and this
movie nails that culture it's really
kind of satirizing that's ironic
it's satirizes it but in a way it's on
the honour of martial arts is is
Congress is there it's there it is yeah
it's not [ __ ] on the whole culture
of martial arts as well
it's just [ __ ] on people that take
it too far or in one direction it was
just the pros oh there's a problem in
this one dojo let's just say that yeah
it was this this one guy that was yeah
yeah there was that Prop Connor that's
why I said it kind of reminded me of
Karate Kid remember the guy who ran the
bad dojo
yeah Cobra Kai Cobra Kai and there was a
situation like that going on yeah and
honor had to be restored and things had
to be set right that's as far as I'm
gonna go with yeah and the saying about
this move yeah and and you have to read
in between the lines you have to
remember what you're told about the
history of the dojo and and this martial
art and certain people's ability to do
[ __ ] crazy things of martial law
that's what I meant about the end being
like the punchline of a very long day
yeah I find out that it's kind of like
the one-inch punch but I'm not gonna get
that really but like I said if you're
really really into this is definitely
not gonna be for everybody who's gonna
be very polarising
it's kind of a weird like I said it's it
has an i rod
distance like from its characters
there's no score yeah so you know
there's long periods of like awkward
silence and stuff like that so but like
I said if you're into like Wes Anderson
movies or anything it's kind of like
weird quirky you know type of indie
movies especially from the 90s in the
early noughties yeah and I think you
will probably really did this I thought
it was hilarious yeah and like there was
one part where I thought they were kind
of like satirizing self defense in terms
of like the Second Amendment and gun
rights which they did kind of satirize
it but then in the end not really
yeah it's just he just got to give the
movie time yeah you give the movie time
and yeah yeah this is one that I'm glad
I didn't know a lot about and then I
just kind of let it unspool right
because it was like it delighted me like
the wind
yeah but it went in particular jerk I
[ __ ] hate art movies but I liked this
one this is one I would actually own
yeah because there was a lot of true is
a minute yeah there's a lot of truisms
in it
and it kind of it took time for the
truth for the truth to come full but
yeah I joined it yeah I enjoyed it it
was a pleasant surprise
yeah I thought was just gonna be zany
from definitely not zany no it is
definitely a dark comedy yeah and it did
have a lot of late 80s Early 90s
nostalgia feel to the set there's only
one thing that they got wrong with in
terms of in terms of like props and
stuff when he goes in to buy the gun
then some of the guns on the back of the
wall in there we're modern yeah that was
stuff that was all what they probably
did was they probably just shot at those
guns
so most guns didn't exist in the 90s
yeah because like I said they don't make
a big deal about what year this was set
I didn't even realize that it was
supposed to be the early 90s until I was
like what does anybody have cellphones
or the internet and why is he like
getting porn out of a magazine
well you see those hours and then yeah
like then when I saw like the computer
monitor I'm like oh this must be like
1991 or soon as I saw that coffee
machine that coffee machine was from the
[ __ ] yeah man I haven't seen one yeah
that was like the first scene I owe the
shop yeah I owned one of those you could
get him at a local drive store or local
drugstore like ten bucks yeah cuz they
made him all the way back into the 70s
so they had this 70s look but you could
buy them forever like for 11 bucks I
guess it didn't occur to me I thought he
was a mr. coffee I think yeah I thought
he was just like it's some old like
cheap-ass diner that just had an old
[ __ ] coffee pub no that was the one
at oz I certainly oh the one at the
office I want the office thing okay I
didn't even notice
yeah like I said I'd even the thing that
said that the tagged it for me was like
I said it's like why is he looking at
titties in a magazine instead of on the
Internet oh yeah and then I was like oh
it's these people didn't have the
Internet yeah so that's why but yeah
definitely if you like this kind of like
dark comedy indie or like I said it goes
almost in a horror movie directly but
kind of about a loser trying to learn to
be a man yeah and there's a lot of [ __ ]
about Matt about about what it takes to
be a man it comes up in this lot yeah
which is it was some funny [ __ ] there
was some truisms to that - yeah it's
satirizing it but so in a way in but
sort of not sort of nice yeah gotta see
it yeah you had just up see it okay so
yeah I definitely recommend it if you
like that kind of thing
you
we're Brian our second new movie of the
week was one that we actually watched on
Netflix yeah this was a little horror
flick called mercy black yeah now this
movie um it's I don't think it got a
theatrical release or anything like that
and weirdly they kind of just dropped it
on Netflix without any prior fanfare
yeah or anything like that it was like
the end of March I think and um you know
just just kind of showed up on there and
it's got its got gods and their actors
in there you'd recognize - yeah Austin
Emilia was in it and who most people
would probably recognize as Dwight from
The Walking Dead the burned face inside
yeah also that Janeane Garofalo and who
I hadn't seen for ages and ages she's
she's looking good actually
she was in a back in those movies from
that she was a stand-up comedian back to
the 90s dude I really liked her she was
in reality bites and mystery man and a
bunch of other movies I thought it was a
decent horeb of unions it's a modern
movie you know I mean yes and really
it's kind of based on the look like it
was kind of based off that tall man
Slender Man slender man there's a
stabbing yeah I didn't mind the movie I
mean I'm getting kind of old I like
nostalgia movies I like this new 18 the
stalls are things in the eighties and
the nineties and this dog thing that
they're doing lately because I can
relate to that a lot better yeah you
know I mean I see [ __ ] that I recognize
I like it and also you know it
eliminates cellphones from the movie
well like I said I think that might be a
big factor into why a lot of newer
movies like let's set stuff back in the
70s and 80s and nobody had cell phones
because we have cell phones yeah yeah
that like a lot of the horror movie
scared scary [ __ ] that happens like you
know as soon as you can like call
somebody or you know call 911 or
something it makes certain kinds of
horror impossible yeah so really you
have to like not have that yeah you see
a ghost and then you get on the internet
access you know who is this is anybody
no they aren't in my house
yeah
died here before yeah and you know and
but ain't no is okay yeah it's like
that's the thing it's it seems like it
kind of um I liked it but it
disappointed me because I thought it had
such a cool premise like it's obviously
based on like I said the very famous
Slenderman stabbings which I think
happened in 2014 like those girls that
said they stabbed their classmate to
death or yeah they stabbed her because
they thought that Slenderman told them
to or something like that so you can
tell that it's bait that it's pretty
directly based on that the guy that
wrote it also based it a little bit on
the very famous case of Mary Belle that
little girl that strangled those two
toddlers I think she was 10 I was back
in the 60s in England so you know the
whole the whole um premise of the movie
it's like you see at the beginning you
know there's these three girls and two
of them like hit this other girl in the
head they take her out to the woods or
whatever and they hit her in the head
with a rock and stabbed her or whatever
it is they do and then you kind of cut
forward to like 15 years later where one
of the little girls has been let out of
the mental hospital and she goes to stay
with her sister and then there's like a
whole thing over whether you know the
this movies version of slender man who
is like called mercy black who's like a
woman like a ghost and I guess they like
constructed her like out of like tree
limbs and like a creepy paper mache mask
or something they actually look pretty
good it did actually it was pretty
creepy and um but I you know I liked I
think I liked the first part of it
because they kept it ambiguous as to
whether mercy black was real or if she
was just having like a mental breakdown
or she just imagined it or the more
intriguing idea that maybe they believed
it so hard that they made it real you
know what I mean so that so they kind of
kept it like you know a little bit
ambiguous and I thought that was pretty
cool then the end it's like I didn't
mind the end like I'm not gonna say what
the what the big twist was or anything
like that but I you know I don't know
if I would have gone that route but you
know I can see how they would go out to
go that route it's I don't know it's
like it had like a lot of like all the
acting performances are really good I
really liked austin emilio in this i
think he was like this sister's
boyfriend and he was kind of a skis and
he was super into like true crime and
stuff and he kind of wanted to exploit
the girl that had got in the mental
hospital you know like oh we should
write a book together you'll make all
kind of money yeah and all this other
kind of stuff and then also he was kind
of like a little rapey to just for the
cherry on top
hmm so you know so there was a whole
thing so I really liked him in the movie
and you know the the woman that played
you know the main character I think her
name was marina she was really good too
but it's like I wish that they had done
something a little bit more original I
guess I mean it just it seems like such
a cool premise for and I feel like they
could have done something more with it
they could have made it scarier they
could have made it like it was good but
it could have been a lot better for me
it was it was more like the tone yeah it
was it was kind of a serious almost kind
of semi realistic tone yeah and there's
something about about newer horror
movies I think maybe because I don't
know because I just didn't grow up with
them they seemed kind of shake and bake
and quick and easy to do and CG and
everything I mean to me it just kind of
yeah and I think this is I think this is
a Blum House movie too and I think a lot
of them kind of fall into this sort of
cookie cutter area where it's like you
know they're a good way to pass the time
they're not terrible if you want to see
like an okay like kind of creepy horror
movie because you don't have anything
better to do cuz it's rainin or whatever
you know they're perfectly service of
their serviceable so that's whether that
yes for that for that there's genre for
that like niche but something bottom
accountants feel like they lack soul
because the tone yeah feel like if they
were made kind of quickly and made well
by a bunch of people and a cutted in a
company oh yeah well like I said it's
Blum house then they don't it doesn't
really have that
handcrafted field yeah I mean they're uh
they're um you know a studio that makes
horror movies and that's all they do but
they tend to make kind of by-the-book
sort of horror it is you you know
they're not a horror studio like well I
guess I was gonna say a 24 I think they
make things other than horror movies too
but I mean a 24 are more into making
like art house horror movies you know I
mean like they made hereditary they made
midsummer they made they're doing the
lighthouse they're doing like all these
kind of like so they're kind of more
concerned with like directors like
auteur type directors and their singular
vision and stuff whereas Blum house
seems more like the McDonald's of horror
movies I mean I think I think you kind
of get into what yeah and like I said in
McDonald's is good sometimes to like you
know when I've been out drinking it's
like yeah I wouldn't mind like a fish
filet or it has it louder yeah but it's
like you wouldn't want it all the time
and a lot of time you know if you just
keep watching this gets kind of boring
I got watched John Carpenter's The Thing
today you know now that they got it on
blu-ray yeah and you look at a movie
like that and you're kind of immersed in
a reality that you actually believed in
it was real Tamiya and and the guys and
the characters all seem like real people
that you know honestly that's what makes
that move I mean among the million other
things make that movie but I think
that's like the beating heart of that
movie yeah the characters and their
interaction with it yeah an alien
monster you know it doesn't look
realistic today back in the days get a
crappy Nosek yeah but you look at it and
you know that it won it's really there
yeah and it guys actually worked on that
need that yeah you know and they worked
real hard on so although you know what
in the new blu-ray version that I saw
you could see the matte paintings you
can see the brushstrokes in the matte
paintings and it's obviously paintings
Wow you know like that the place where
the flying saucer was down and say yeah
you know inside the ice and [ __ ] like
that you know you know I love a good man
painting yeah you could see the
brushstrokes and the map to me I don't
mind if that stuff looks fake cuz like
you said at least it's still there cuz
CGI looks fake to me too yeah but it
didn't look that way on film back on the
lower resolutions and where that here
that movie came from that's kind of a
shitty thing I see
let's make everything a super high
definition you go that's a painting but
it doesn't look like that way it doesn't
look like that in a theater it's like
yeah there comes a point where yeah I
don't want a too high definite yes it's
kind of like ruin the ocean is on that
they should have left it should have
lowered the definition or something on
that yeah I did because it was a nice
painting but you could tell you can see
the brush it's the painting is baby yeah
we've we had the same thing we're
watching the father maybe as well the
other thing but yeah so like I said I'm
gonna say like if you have you know an
hour and 45 minutes to kill you feel
like watching kind of a creepy but you
know not a horror movies gonna like
traumatize you or gross you out or
anything like that and you don't really
have to like pay super amount of
attention to then this is a perfectly
fine workman like horror movie it's you
know it's it's fun it's like a good
company doesn't do the contouring and
all that yeah it's definitely it's like
it's it's weird to me because like as I
watch like a lot of horror channels cuz
you know I'm kind of a geek about horror
and I feel like the conjuring the first
one is unlike a lot of people's like you
know best horror movies of the 2000s or
2000 tons or whatever the [ __ ] that came
out um
lists and stuff and I'm not gonna like
argue with you about it like I think the
first conjuring was obviously really
good and like all the other ones in the
conjuring universe have been kind of
like meth most of them now we have yeah
we've seen like a you know a great deal
of the kind of extended universe ones um
but I I don't like I like the first
conjuring but not as much as a lot of
other people seem to like it
like to me it seems like it's a good
movie and it's got like some creepy
scenes in it but I don't love it as much
as after you see a couple of those
movies you know exactly what you're
gonna get there's kind of a formula to
it you kind of know about the jump
scares the highlight yeah that's kind of
the problem there it's like a formula
the highlight of that movies those
movies are seeing them in theaters with
a bunch of [ __ ] teenagers in them
yeah with everybody like screaming
scream at ei are [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
today well I think what it oh let's call
me you know you can hide there oh no
honestly I don't know
about that but I think it's just because
it's it's fun to let go with your
friends yeah and like it's in a dark
room and you just likes you know so I
think they psyched themselves up for it
I hear the boys back there trying to
talk to off and [ __ ] because they were
scared well yeah I know yeah yeah yes I
heard that and it's like well and the
thing about it too is that you know I'm
not averse to like a well-executed
jump-scare yeah but if all that is in
your movie that's not a scare
you're just startling someone with a
loud noise yeah I can do that by
sneaking up behind somebody and popping
a balloon that last one had a couple
pretty cool shots I don't remember the
name of that last time so remembering
that one effect where she was shining
the flashlight which one to Annabelle
comes someone Annabelle comes home with
she was looking down the hallway and saw
this creepy looking eyes oh the coins
yeah and then when she shouldn't that
was cool the coins and then they fill
the ground that's pretty [ __ ] cool I
liked that scene yeah most of those
movies have like really cool like
visuals yeah mm yeah it's just that I
mean that one was actually not bad yeah
um you know I enjoyed it while we're
watching change it up a little bit yeah
it's just that I think the problem with
a lot of horror movies you know whether
they're in the theater or whether they
you know come straight to Netflix it's a
lot of them are good like while you're
watching them but you don't remember
them they don't stick with you they're
just kind of forgettable but I guess
that's true of like most movies from
from all of the time there's only like a
few that are gonna like stick with you
forever best one of that company that
I've seen I've seen was La Llorona and
only the first half of it
yeah the first half of La Llorona I'd
really like that one I mean we started
showing it too much yeah I mean like I
said I liked the first conjuring movie
it's just that I don't I wouldn't like
put it in my best ones of that decade
yeah because there were a lot of just
because and that's me it's like if other
people where that's like no you know I'm
not gonna [ __ ] on you for that but I
think there was just a lot of ones that
to me were more memorable I like ones
that like do something different you
know I mean I tend to like ones that
have like a concept that they do
something different with or they or they
try to more build an atmosphere of dread
like I said
other than just like popping up in your
face every but I think that most members
that's just annoying most memorable new
one recently he asked me would be it it
part one I think that actually was much
better than I was expecting and I'm like
looking forward to the second one yeah
that was good that was pretty good
mine was hereditary I love that [ __ ]
movie and it bothered me a lot and that
never happens like that families really
didn't do much for me I fell asleep
during it but I know but like it though
it you know it's a little bit divisive
but it's from what I've read of like a
lot of other people had the same
reaction to it as I did I mean it was
like an instant classic
so and it it bothered me so much that I
don't think I won that he did I thought
was better midsummer midsummer was
better good I like to read it Terry
better than midsummer but it's hard to
compare them because I know it's the
same director but it's hard to compare
them because they were really different
like in their approaches you know that's
why it's I hate having to do like oh
this one's better than that because
they're totally different types of
movies I mean they were to eat this
totally going for a difference so you
recommend this one well like I said if
you don't have anything better to do
like don't I'm not saying like on a bad
move rush out and watch it like you have
to see this it's like the best movie
it's a perfectly fine yeah you know if
you're like hanging out Friday night
you're bored just get some pizza and
just like oh I kind of want to watch a
scary movie but nothing too traumatizing
then you you know you could certainly do
worse there's nothing wrong with it
it's just nothing special yeah for me it
was kind of like the other ones yeah
that's a just well it was well made yeah
it's well made well executed but you
know it's not it's kind of creepy it
hasn't been like you know the Mersey
black little the mask and the and the
body and everything that had some like
kind of creepy shots and stuff like that
but you know it's you're not gonna like
remember it the next day but you know
like I said you could do worse that's
not a ringing endorsement
[Music]
you
okay here we are were there a third
movie for our matinee show and we also
went to the theater to see this one and
it was Quentin Tarantino's latest film
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
yeah I'll tell you what is a masterpiece
I think it was - I can see how it's
gonna be a little divisive because it's
a little bit unlike some of his other
movies in some ways but I mean I thought
it was amazing and it was like 2 hours
and 41 minutes long and it wasn't even
like I could have watched that all day
yeah you know seriously I didn't think
it was yeah I didn't want the movie to
end yeah yeah this one and I'm not I'm
not easy on Quentin Tarantino I actually
don't only like half of his stuff yeah
and out of it out of the movies that
he's done
I only partially likes the ones that I
like yeah like I liked Reservoir Dogs
which I to me kind of was like a play
more than a movie and I liked was that
other one the one with the Pulp Fiction
Pulp Fiction yeah yeah yeah Pulp Fiction
I always get Pulp Fiction and true
romance romance I think he just wrote
that I don't think he directed okay yeah
but I like to pulp fiction even though
man there's certain Tarantino isms in
those movies that drove me up the wall
that kind of zany dialogue ridiculous
[ __ ] um
Tarantino putting himself in the movie
and kind of not really fitting in and
with his terrible dialogue and [ __ ] and
just but this one didn't have Tarantino
problems the Tarantino problems weren't
there but all the strengths of Quentin
Tarantino were there yeah like a good
way of putting it yeah this is
definitely like okay this is the easily
the most chill Tarantino movie at least
till the end yeah it's a very lived-in
movie um it's like a hangout movie I've
seen some people like compare it to the
Big Lebowski or Dazed and Confused where
it's just kind of like a lot of the
running time and I know a lot of
Tarantino movies have this but a lot of
the running time is just like characters
like hanging out to get
like talking and stuff but because you
like the character so much boring it's
not more like I didn't find it boring at
all like I said even though it was long
I could have watched it all day I mean
especially the interaction between the
two main characters you know Brad Pitt
and Leonardo DiCaprio you know who were
playing you know cliff booth who was a
stunt man that was Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio was playing Rick
Dalton it was like a fading TV Western
star and like their friendship like as
you watched the movie it felt like
they've been friends forever
like you could really feel the weight of
the history that they had with each
other the theme of the movies basically
kind of like friendship and loyalty
between Bros really does yeah that was
that was kind of the emotional core yeah
this is you like the ultimate [ __ ]
broma bromance me in a way and you have
a lot of really cool elements in this
story that really make it like the
stuntman is up is a is a war hero who's
like injured he's all scarred up [ __ ]
you know they play by Brad Pitt and he's
uh truly heroic guy but he's got a past
- and it's very like realistic kind of
situation and his loyalty to the guy
that he works for who's you know this
actor is is it's awesome it's just
awesome and they were there just talking
about well really they're just you just
did they're just going through the the
situation of being a Hollywood actor at
that time and trying to make it yet out
of it yeah and it's got a lot of realism
to it
there was no I liked yeah now look and
you see they you know Hollywood stars
from the past appear you know being
played by other people of course because
a lot of we're dead but you know you
know Steve McQueen shows up and then
Steve McQueen tells your stories and
Bruce Lee shows up and then certain
things happen yeah Bruce Lee that was
like one of the best scenes and I don't
want to do any spoilers in this one yeah
definitely we can boil it for anybody
I'm sure that I mean just from the
trailers you know that like the Manson
Family is involved because this whole
thing takes place most of it actually
takes place in February of 1969 and
there's kind of like a lot of buildup
and really even though like the Manson
Family is kind of like on the fringes
yeah don't spoil it don't don't say
nothing yeah yeah but like um the reason
why the Manson families in this is
because Dalton the actor lives next door
to Roman Polanski and Sharon Tate yeah
alright on on the night which like I
said that's not a spoiler because that
wasn't that's not a spoiler that was
announced in there you're gonna see
Sharon Tate and everything they they
just you know and each of these each of
these actors that kind of you know they
give them their own kind of backgrounds
of the stories what's what's going on
and in this year and what letter
led up to that night and really the the
movie kind of ends on what happened that
night if you know history you know what
happened but this is a very different
take I don't want to [ __ ] spoil on it
yeah take on what happened and tell you
what man this movie delivered this is
like a man's man's man this little
[ __ ] tons of bros [ __ ] going on in it
and it it ends up being very satisfying
because you you know the audience gets
to see what they want to see and it's
just a very spam I shouldn't tell you
it's like at the end of this movie and
this is not a spoiler but at the end of
this movie everybody in the theater went
ape [ __ ] yeah they were class and then
like after the movie was over everyone
applauded yeah they were and it was like
it was almost fall the theater I was it
this one so far is in my humble but yet
informed opinion about Quentin Tarantino
movies this is his Kubrick moment this
is a [ __ ] like this is this is this
is this is his version of The Shining
it's a [ __ ] masterpiece yeah what is
it like I said I think that something
that really makes it like I said is you
know the the relationship between the
two main characters there's a bunch
other characters there's a lot of other
stuff going on like a run the outside
it's like I said here in Hollywood these
people yeah it's like it doesn't really
I mean the narrative it has one but it's
very loose it's kind of more like it's
kind of more like a bunch of like
characters like surrounding essential
theme yeah like I said the theme mostly
friendship loyalty also second chances
yeah I think that's kind of a big
because you know Rick it's not over
until you say it's over
yeah I mean Daulton is kind of like I
mean the whole point of his you know
thing and like I said this isn't a
spoiler either because they also put
this in the trailer where it's like he
thinks that he's becoming a has-been you
know because he was like on TV westerns
and stuff so it's it's kind of like him
trying to redeem himself and like I said
this the friendship with Brad Pitt's
character the stunt man and his kind of
ambiguous past and things that he does
in the present and it's almost like I
think this might be my favorite role and
Brad Pitt is actually really good is
awesome in this comedic Agutter and he
doesn't really get enough chance to do
that um I think he was in like Burn
After Reading I think where he was like
really funny in that but he doesn't
really get a chance to do that very
often but he is great in this he is just
like and the weird thing about this and
I never thought I would say this about a
Quentin Tarantino movie even though you
know the end of it you you know you get
the gore you get the kind of stuff
that's like you know if you liked you
know inglourious basterds or Django and
change or something like that you're not
going to be like super surprised but you
know there is violence and stuff in it
but it's almost like it's a weirdly
heartwarming and I never thought I would
say that about a Quentin Tarantino movie
it was it's sweet it was a well the
characters are all really good real
strong characters yeah even the even the
villains in this are kind of strong in
the wedding they're very believable yeah
and you know exactly what they're
talking about especially we're talking
about the massive family and stuff it's
just I don't know man just I just I was
watching it and I was going man I really
love this movie
want this movie to add yeah I just
wanted it to keep going even it's like
this is the kind of movie and I can see
how this is gonna be divisive it's like
some people might think oh it's so
boring blah blah blah like I can see the
movie I did not find it boring at all
like I said I could just watch like Brad
Pitt driving around in a car yeah in his
like Coupe de Ville or whatever it was
like listening to [ __ ] on the radio
taking out girls picking up girls I
could watch that all day long just
because the characters that they
established were just so good and it's
like you know there's scenes where
they're just like hanging out drinking
beer watching TV you know what I'm
talking to the dog and like talking to
the dog and it was great it's like and
that's what I mean it just seemed like
this liyan experience and it seemed not
only like you were back in 1969 you were
their friends it yeah it felt like you
were their friends and this also seemed
paced very much like a movie for him
back then you could almost believe that
this was made in 1969 yeah you could
almost believe that just from the way it
looked
I'm not sure what film stock he shot it
on but it looked very much like a movie
of that era I mean all the [ __ ] they did
like when they're driving around the
streets of Hollywood the streets of LA
it looks like as many books but just
like 1969 and it was like mind-blowing
yeah I left an 81 yeah and some of us
wishes I recognized like the old der
Wienerschnitzel yeah that was good I
remember that the way the inside the
Mexican restaurants look like back then
they're looking just like that and he
said you can smell it I can smell it as
soon as I saw the inside of that Mexican
restaurant I'd grew up in that kind of
[ __ ] soon as I saw that the California
Mexican restaurant I could smell like I
hit by the smell of damn fresh fresh
deep fried tortilla shells and beer yeah
yeah that's what they smell but it was
like that and it's just like I mean this
has some of the like trademark Tarantino
stuff it's like you know he there's
trailers for like you know obscure
movies from back then and like posters
and stuff like that some of them are
real some of them are fictional like
some of the brands you know or not real
like the dog food that was like
hilarious but um you know it's just
every detail on this is just so
meticulously
realized but it's also kind of like I
said it's realistic but it's also kind
of
like a fairytale which is I think why he
called it once upon a time in Hollywood
and other than harkening back to once
upon a time in the way he's still
essentially a Western I'm watching the
movie and it seems kind of like a
fictionalized historical movie yeah
that's what with a couple of a couple of
new characters kind of inserted into it
yeah then towards the end it almost kind
of goes fantasy yeah it's the fantasy
that you wanted to see yeah it's the way
you wish them so Tarantino's giving you
the ending you want yeah which I like
that well it's also making like a larger
point too and I can't really say what
that is like without spoiling it but he
is making a larger like somatic yeah
point with what he did with the end of
the movie you know what I mean that has
to do with like the character arcs of
why do the main characters it's to me
it's a masterpiece this is this is this
is Tarantino's best movie and it is a it
is one of the best movies I've seen now
I'm gonna say that it's one it's really
good I mean if I go see the more I
thought about it you saw it like late
last night and the more I thought about
it today the more I want to like see it
again yeah I wanna see you I wanna own
it you know what I mean it's like it's
it'd almost be worth seeing it again on
the big screen yeah it was just like it
was just like so all the detail and it
was just like such a richly entailed
like I just liked it a lot of characters
yeah it's like all of them were like
even the villains like you said we're
like still likeable or compelling and
rough enough that you were just so
invested in them that you could just
watch them like hang out or drive around
or something like that it was just like
that and certain things are not kind of
what's a good way to put it
things are put in the proper perspective
like the average person might be freaked
out by the Manson Family but a [ __ ]
war heroes and the weapons freaked out
by the Manson Family you just had this
he had his own view of them you just
have to see yeah I mean he didn't know
who they were but you know because
nobody knew who they were but that
didn't matter to him though yeah it
should not cause they gonna be like yeah
he was intimidated so and he wasn't eat
why didn't we say he wouldn't even
intimidated by Bruce Lee that's how much
spoilers
this is one of the funniest scenes in
the movie I mean other than the last
part which was just like [ __ ] up in
hilarious and like I said the whole
theater just went apeshit yeah um but
it's just just well like I said it's
it's [ __ ] up but it's hilarious
Tarantino telling you his Hollywood
story yeah that's exactly what this is
and it's a mythology but in reality
based in reality like I said and it's
not it's not as over-the-top as some of
his other ones you know inglourious
basterds was kind of over the top Django
Unchained was a little bit over the top
but this one the end is kind of over the
top but not really got that over the top
not really that over that could
definitely have yeah yeah and but like I
said everything leading up to that is
just like this wonderful like yeah he'll
kind of languid sort of journey with
these people that you like and you feel
like you get to know them you know I
walked out of there [ __ ] feeling very
satisfied because it had the ending an
ending that I was satisfied with as a
good ending yeah and the characters that
you liked it all turned out the way it
really kind of should have turned out
yeah it was like I said yeah that's a
good way of putting it's a very
satisfying yeah I'm like you could
actually make a sequel to this you could
yeah good although in some ways I think
it's better to just leave it to like
everyone's imagining I can imagine what
would have happened next right yeah you
know what I mean so I think that's kind
of cool because you get like imagine the
way it is but yeah I mean if you like
Tarantino and you've seen all this other
movie I don't like Tarantino you don't
like Tarantino you might like it too
because because I think a lot of his
like affectations are definitely like
toned way down in this one but like you
said all of his strengths like playing
on his strengths and he's kind of toning
down his weaknesses I think if you could
have vanished yeah the things that some
things I didn't like about him weren't
there in this movie yeah you know which
email I think it was an awesome decision
some might say well that's gonna make it
more like a conventional movie yeah but
Tarantino had a lot to bring to the
table he didn't have to do
he doesn't really had to do any gimmicky
[ __ ] like he was doing yeah and some of
the his in his earlier movies there was
some gimmicky stuff and every Tarantino
signatures and [ __ ] which I thought kind
of muddied the movie up but he did make
a name on it so Who am I Who am I
yeah and that's gonna that's all gonna
be down to like subjective opinion yeah
it's like some people are gonna dig that
some people not so much like I said this
really does I mean you can tell he loves
movies he loves the 1960s you know that
whole even though you know he wasn't
alive through most of it but you can
tell it's a Tarantino movie don't get me
wrong
oh yeah yeah yeah it's Tarantino like it
definitely has his signature all over a
lot of his weird quirks I didn't like
are not in this movie yeah so I'm gonna
say this is his best movie and I could
tell just by the reaction of the
audience that they were just [ __ ]
loving this movie yeah and like I said I
mean I'm coming from a point of view
where it's like I like most of Quentin
Tarantino's but I'm not a super fan or
anything but you know I loved Pulp
Fiction I loved Reservoir Dogs I loved
you know most of his other ones so you
know I'm just coming in from like an
ambivalent I'll just take it or leave it
kind of thing but I ended up like loving
it and like I said I was just like
watching I was just riveted like that's
it I bet I gotta take him back though
you know the trailer they showed him
with the flamethrower saying who ordered
fried sauerkraut yeah that was a
Tarantino mom moment that was a st.
[ __ ] moment well in that way I was
told in the context of the movie that
that guy was making yeah that wasn't
what actually happened in real life that
was taken from a scene that he was in
and that that character made in a movie
in this movie and that was a movie is
making other movies and that was also
kind of like a winking reference back to
inglorious ass kids so he that was like
a like a two or three layer so there is
a joke there is some signature Tarantino
goofiness and [ __ ] like that but it
plays a lot better in the in this story
because that is happening inside a movie
inside a movie yeah it's like it one
remove and you're like almost kind of
you're kind of encouraged to see it as
like cheesy and over-the-top yeah cuz
you're seeing it again no I was making
cheesy movies right so and that was one
of this scenes from the cheesy move
yes I feel like this is that word like I
feel like Quentin Tarantino like he
could have only made this like at the
age that he's at now yeah because it
almost seems like it's a very personal
film for him it felt like a very
personal and crosses in it
he is crosses in it it narrates parts of
it yeah this is voice game wanted to be
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah anyway like
I said that's it I really really like
this movie a lot like I said it's gonna
be a little divisive it seems like the
reviews have mostly been like largely
very very positive but you know if you
like Quentin Tarantino and you want to
see something that yet his chillest
movie ever but also with an infected
anything PC or soy-based not this movie
this movie is pure [ __ ] testosterone
those [ __ ] soy in this movie not an
ounce well like this is a great school
Hollywood never real looks like chimney
and everyone's be wrong reeking like
crap this is a real move like I said it
could almost have been made back then
yeah like the lights yeah it's just
really really good and like I said I
kind of want to go to the theater and
see it yes yeah yeah we're talking about
it again yeah so definitely I we
definitely both recommend that
you